I would just like to begin by saying
thank you to the academy because for
those that do not know every year the
Oscar for costume design is presented by
the most stylish and fashion forward
actress in Hollywood
and Paul Dano
being named for an Oscar is the second
greatest honor a costume designer can
receive the greatest honor is when an
actor accidentally takes their
beautifully designed costume home with
them
seeing these Exquisite designs up close
you know exactly why their designers are
nominated tonight and exactly why they
might end up hidden in an actor's car
trunk or gym bag and by the way Julia
yes that is a gorgeous dress you're
wearing oh
so much
Christmas
for achievement in costume design
Babylon costume designed by Mary
zoffries
Black Panther wakanda forever costume
designed by Ruth Carter
Elvis costume designed by Catherine
Martin
[Music]
everything everywhere all at once
costume designed by Shirley carata
Mrs Harris goes to Paris costume
designed by Jenny Bevin
[Music]
[Applause]
two
black panther wakanda forever Ruth
Carter
thank you
Ruth Carter's first job in film was
designing costumes for Spike Lee's 1988
film school days Ruth Carter utilized 3D
printing technology to create a crown
and neck piece for Queen ramonda in
Black Panther wakanda forever wow
nice
nice again
thank you to the academy for recognizing
the superhero that is a black woman
oh
she endures she loves she overcomes she
is every woman in this film
she is my mother this past week Mabel
Carter became an ancestor
this film prepared me for this moment
Chadwick please take care of Mom
Ryan coogler Nate Moore thank you both
for your vision together we are
reshaping how culture is represented
the Marvel family Kevin Fahey
Victoria Alonso Louis D Esposito and
their arsenal of Genius thank you I
share this with many dedicated artists
whose hands and hearts helped manifest
the costumes of wakanda and tolacon
this is for my mother she was 101.